salut à tous cette vidéo est encore
sponsorisée par norvpn nvpn c'est un
outil qui te permet de contourner les
géorestrictions comme par exemple pour
avoir le Netflix US pour le catalogue ou
le Netflix japonais pour les animés
regardez les matchs de foot ou des
courses de F1 en changeant ton IP ou
même les programmes français depuis
l'étranger oh comment j'ai pu faire sans
ça norvpn te protège des maloware grâce
à sa fonction cybersec les nouveaux
serveurs de Paris et Marseille te
garantissent une vitesse et une sécurité
optimal et tu bénéficies de six
appareils en même temps avec un seul
compte et comment j'ai pu faire sans
ça en ce moment tu peux bénéficier d'un
abonnement de 2 ans à prix réduit avec
un cadeau bonus et 30 jours satisfaits
ou remboursés uniquement en cliquant sur
le lien en description alors qu'est-ce
que vous attendez
[Musique]
nouvelle imbroglio judiciaire pour le
multimilliardaire Laurent Croft une
nouvelle fois dans la tourmente après le
pillage d'un cimtière de bébé aveugle
mais non mais ce n'est pas un aventurier
il ne vit aucune aventure non ben écoute
écoutez écoutez le journaliste ici c'est
moi mais enfin mais mais enfin mais vous
êes mais vous êtes un vous êtes un
coprofage non monsieur tête d'épinard
non non non non mais vous êtes un
courbeur de banane ça n'est pas possible
qu'est-ce que c'est tous les
jours j'aime offrir à mon corps des
soins et sans transition nous sommes
quelque part entre le 10 et le 12
septembre 2021 et nous célébrons le
triste anniversaire de rien du tout il
ne s'est rien passé il y a 20 ans et
tout de suite la
météo bah écoutez il fait beau on va pas
se
mentir qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
mer Winston
[Musique]
Winston dites-moi qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de MOI exactement je dirais
monsieur que vous êtes un gros un fils
de dégénéré et lubrique un trou du
doublé d'un et pour conclure le roi des
merci Winston de rien
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se
passe alors tous les tétés et les
zouzous ont disparu n'est-ce
[Rires]
[Musique]
pas 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rappelez-moi votre nom Tonio Madi c'est
ça c'est là c'est quelque part par là
vous voulez pas prendre une douche
d'abord je
[Musique]
l'ai la légende du mystérieux dollar
vert un artefact ancestral caché
dissimulé aux yeux du monde par une
antique
civilisation il a porté bien les noms la
mouaka et Dino et le myth raconte qu'un
seul homme a réussi à poser la main
dessus archibalde de von grenier mais je
le connais c'est moi avec une moustache
peu importe qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
[Applaudissements]
ensuite le
mystérieux ver il est à moi non à moi
donnez-moi le dollar ver
archibal le guide que j'ai engagé dans
les B de Bogota cont de boucher de pain
mais comment avez-vous pu désolé
monsieur une
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
FAM oh Pierre Henry Judas mon fidèle ami
d'enfance qui m'accompagne partout dans
mes aventures depuis près de 15 ans mais
comment avez-vous pu désolé archibalde
mais entre le pognon et vous j'ai choisi
le
[Musique]
pognon
chafa le grand vizir d'agraba mais
comment avez-vous pu
oui oui oui oui c'est bon j'ai compris
il y a eu des trahisons mais du coup où
est le mystérieux dollar
vert salut à tous il existe des licences
qui ont marqué le monde du jeu vidéo
pour l'éternité Sonic Mario Assassin's
Creed ho ou encore Tomb Raider Tomb
Raider c'est un de ces jeux qui ont
marqu marqu un tournant dans l'histoire
des jeux vidéos puisque c'est à cette
époque et avec des jeux comme Tomb
Raider ou Mario 64 qu'on comprend
vraiment ce qu'est un jeu en 3D et
pourtant quand je vous dis Tomb Raider
vous voyez quoi dans votre esprit le jeu
non bien sûr vous voyez Lara Croft
l'héroïne a complètement éclipser le jeu
et pourtant on était pas parti pour ça
au début la première version du héros de
Tomb Raider était un homme mais très
trop proche d'Indiana Jones il avait
même un fouet c'estd il fut décidé alors
de prendre une héroïne finalement c'est
un design de femme latino qui fut
retenue du nom de Laura Cruz qui
finalement fut modifiée pour sonner plus
anglais Lara Croft
ça va déjà on vous met une gonzesse vous
allez pas en plus réclamer une étrangère
le personnage playofille elle est belle
elle a des courbes elle assume sa
féminité elle n'est ni une princesse à
sauveré ni un garçon manqué et le
personnage plaît au garçon parce que la
puberté et du coup évidemment avec son
côté très bel femme ça n'a pas attendu
longtemps pour en faire un genre de
pinup du jeu vidéo pu à la télé dans les
magazines sur des couverture la racroft
c'est bien la racroft à poil c'est mieux
et cette sexualisation qu'elle n'avait
pas du tout à l'origine d'ailleurs n'a
pas trop plu à son créateur qui a quitté
corordesign en partie à cause de ça
attends comment ça s'appelle quand on
prend une belle meuf et qu'on la fou à
poil contre son gré pour gagner de
l'argent du proxin teams du marketing
voilà merci ben oui c'est un rêve
mouillé de marqueteuse ça imaginer elle
peut même pas dire qu'elle est pas
d'accord Tomb Raider est donc un puzzle
platformer sorti sur PS1 développé par
Core Design et édité par par idos
interactive sorti en 96 on y joue le
personnage de Lara crof une aventurière
archéologue mais qui a un problème avec
tout ce qui est précieux et à votre
gauche la muraille de Chine une des SEP
merveilles du
monde oh mon Dieu on a retrouvé le
temple de
l'Atlantide regardez c'est le dernier
dinosaure vivant sur
terre bref on parcourera le monde pour
trouver des arfact perdu venant de
civilisation du tier monde afin d'en
ramener les richesses chez soi j'appelle
ça l'histoire de
l'Occident je veux dire genre elle a
large d'alliance dans son entrée c'est
même pas exposé c'est genre elle s'en
sert pour poser le sac de course quand
elle arrive et on prendra un grand
plaisir à rentrer dans des grottes
inexplorées et à poser le pied dans des
tombeaux que nul humain n'a foulé depuis
des milliers d'années cool une
mitraillette si le jeu a eu un succès ça
n'est pas que à cause de sa colossale
pare de loche qui d'ailleurs est dû à
une erreur d'un des développeurs qui a
foutu sa poitrine à 150 % au lieu de 50
ouais une erreur c'est aussi pour son
gameplay et ses innovations il faut bien
comprendre qu'on est encore là dans la
période où les jeux sont en train de
passer de la 2D à la 3D et le fait
qu'onit un jeu permettant de courir
sauter plonger nager tirer s'agripper à
des parois tirer des blocs activer des
interrupteurs faire des roulades marcher
faire
le le poirier bon ok ça ça sert à rien
et ben tout ça c'était énorme à l'époque
et le jeu dans sa globalité est même
trufé de bonnes idées comme par exemple
le manoir des Croft un niveau optionnel
accessible par le menu du jeu qui sert
de tuto et qui est une idée géniale
parce que ça ancre Lara comme étant un
personnage qui vit en dehors de
l'histoire principale en plus de
rajouter de la profondeur en racontant
quelque chose
ça raconte qu'elle est de riche
après le jeu n'est pas exemple de tout
défaut niveau maniabilité sanstique
analogique c'est vraiment Tomb Raider le
personnage est lourd le système de
sauvegarde est épouvantable on a les
classiques problèmes de caméra qui
s'accentuent de plus en plus quand dans
le jeu on commence à rencontrer des
ennemis rapides de plus en plus nombreux
puis on va pas se le cacher l'histoire
des Tomb Raider c'est un énorme nanard
quand tu vois que le scénar du jeu
arrive à vouloir nous placer en restant
sérieux des boss comme un cowboy ou un
gamin qui fait du skate mon petit il
arrive à mettre tort comme un dieu gre
et a transformé la cité de l'Atlantide
en un anus de steché tu sais que tu es
pas devant un julverne bref le jeu a ses
défauts mais ils sont minimes à côté de
tout ce qui est apporté c'est un carton
7 millions de vent le succès est tel que
lar Croft devient même la mascotte
officieuse de la console alors que le
jeu existait aussi sur Saturne et PC
malgré quelques améliorations comme dans
le 2 regardez par exemple elle a une NAT
waouh W et quelques petits changements
dans le gameplay les tomb Raiders
suivants n'atteindront jamais le succès
de l'original er 2 tentera d'apporter
des niveaux plus urbains ce qui apporte
aussi son lot de moment stupide comme ce
moment où tu déclenches un piège qui te
fait tomber des rochets sur la tête
c'est un peu étrange dans un théâtre à
bonise on va pas se mentir mais Tomb
Raider 2 c'est aussi le jeu où le moteur
graphique montrera déjà ses limites
quand tu es dans des cavernes immenses
ou dans des tombes égyptiennes tu peux
accepter un peu n'importe quel décor
hein mais Venise ben tout le monde sait
à quoi ça ressemble et ça ressemble pas
à ça le souci c'est que le moteur de
Tomb Raider n'est pas fait pour afficher
des détails et c'est à cause de ça que
bah tout à l'air hors de proportion ah
bordel les riche je te jure salut c'est
lar crop et je vais vous présenter ma
maison alors vous voyez ça c'est ma
cuisine ça c'est Winston mon major
d'omme j'adore vraiment mon Winston mais
des fois je l'enferme dans le frigo où
je lu mets une cible et je lui tire
dessus appelez la
police ça c'est la salle du tapis c'est
tout ça sert à rien
d'autre ça c'est mes chiottes et j'en ai
mis deux comme ça si je veux je peux ch
avec une copine mais j'ai pas de copine
alors je fais ça avec mon majordom ma
vie n'est qu'une souffrance en niveau
nouveauté il y a pas grandchose de
révolutionnaire Tomb Raider 2 ajoutera
des véhicules Tomb Raider 3 se dira
qu'on pourra en faire des pH de
plateforme ce qui
est
vraiment une
idée de mer et plus les jeux avancent
plus la difficulté va
exploser sérieux Mme les cheat codes
pour passer les niveaux sont difficiles
alors faites un petit pas à gauche un
petit pas à droite un petit pas à gauche
un pas en arrière un petit pas en avant
trois tours sur place un saut en avant
roule
[Musique]
là c'est c'est sympa mais c'est quoi le
code du coup à partir de Tomb Raider 3
les ventes commencent vraiment à chuter
les gens se plaignent que le jeu est
trop dur que la licence tourne en rond
et de toute façon faut aussi comprendre
que à ce moment-là les équipes sont déjà
rincé depuis Tomb Raider 1 l'éditeur
aidos pousse les développeurs à sortir
un jeu par rang c'est colossal on note
même des cas de problèmes de santé
mental dans l'équipe Tomb Raider 2
c'était les idées restantes du 1 Tomb
Raider 3 c'était les idées rejetées Tomb
Raider 4 c'est et ben vois voyez bien
qu'il reste des idées làdedans allez ça
part en prod le rythme est tellement
délirant que les développeurs décident
même de tuer le personnage de Lara Croft
à la fin de Tomb Raider 4 sans le dire à
l'd ou du moins en lui disant au dernier
moment juste pour avoir un peu de répi
et d'ailleurs anecdote he d'après le
wiki du jeu il y a même un des
développeurs qui avait proposé de
décapiter Lara Croft juste pour être sûr
qu'elle soit bien morte mais ça ne
suffira pas mais foutez-nous la paix
vous voyez bien qu'elle est morte pas de
problème vous connaissez les flashbacks
fin 99 début 2000 les développeurs sont
déjà en train de bosser sur Angel of
darkness le futur Tomb Raider de la PS2
et ils doivent évidemment tout reprendre
de zéro parce que c'est une nouvelle
machine mais malgré et ça idos impose de
faire encore un autre Tomb Raider sur
Playstation 1 pour traire la vache
jusqu'à la dernière molécule de
[Musique]
lait c'est donc Tomb Raider 5 qui
revient sur les aventures de Lara Croft
en mode flashback et c'est le jeu de
trop pour le studio les énigmes sont
stupides le jeu est dépassé
graphiquement et techniquement on a des
mécanisme romain géant qui tire des
lasers des ennemis gladiateurs humains
mais attendez ça se passe à notre po ton
Raider c'est quoi il y a vraiment un mec
qui s'est levé un matin il a embrassé sa
femme et salut chéri je m'en vais bosser
un des développeurs en 2016 donnera même
une interview et appellera ce jeu je
cite un gros tas de vieille mercredi
chez
judo coup je serai pas là
[Musique]
jackpot utilise le carnet d'archibalde
tout est doté dedans oh là mais vous
avez mangé une poubelle ou quoi oui
entre autes
Laurent Croft je vais vous délester de
cet encombrant petit
[Musique]
carnet voyons voir ce que vous cachez
là-dedans vous servira à rien car alors
comme ça vous aussi vous êtes à la
recherche du mystérieux dollar ver mais
dites-moi pourquo recherchezv cet objet
je ve m'en servir pour lever la
malédiction qui pè sur le monde faites
ça dans ce cas nous avons le même
but et vous en quoi ça vous concerne
pourquoi vous recherchez ce mystérieux
dollar ver toute cette malédiction ne
concerne pas seulement les tét et les
zouous il y a des choses bien plus
graves en jeu l'isttoire commence en
19 le jeune chancelier souhait récupérer
le dollar vert pour maîtriser son
pouvoirz je comprends rien du tout là
bon bref on doit récupérer le dollar
vert j'en ai besoin autant que vous
mettonsnous au travail il doit y avoir
un indice
là-dessus les indices dans les tableaux
sont souvent dissimulés j'ai emmené une
lampe à lumière
[Musique]
noire rien du tout il doit bien avoir
unice quelque
[Musique]
part j'ai peut-être une idée
ah bon ok c'était pas à Condé sur noire
ouais voilà on va aller à s Bruno alors
fait99 alors qu'une partie des équipes
finit Tomb Raider 5 un nouveau jeu Tomb
Raider commence son développement nom de
code Tomb Raider next generation le ton
est donné hein c'est fini la laracrofte
à papi maintenant on va tout réinventer
le service marketing fait un tas
d'études de marché pour savoir ce que
les gens veulent et vous savez à quel
point c'est toujours une excellente idée
de demander aux gens ce qu'ils veulent
pour un produit culturel donc on va
pomper tout ce qui marche en ce moment
Metal Gear Chen mou et puis tankonier on
va aussi donner à Lara ce côté dark et
edgy typique des années 2000 et quand tu
es un fan de Tomb Raider à ce momentlà
ben tu te dis enfin enfin le renouveau
d'une licence qui tournait en rond
depuis des années le jeu est absolument
partout pub à la télé dans les magazines
interview de Lara crov qui agite son
boule en
direct ça va forcément être gé merde
je commence sur une cinématique
mystérieuse avec une voix qui raconte
que Lara est suspectére
surci M
deer 4 méchant asoir é habité par
l'esprit
[Musique]
deeette
femex
yp ver tu es parti sans te retourner
8 secondes voilà c'est le temps qu'il
aura fallu au jeu pour se chier
[Musique]
dessus parti sans te
retourner c'est déjà le premier moment
où le jeu aurait pu se finir en 5
secondes tu m'as abandonné en Égypte non
ah oui c'est vraiment
qu'elle a
survécu c'est jamais évoqué parce que je
rappelle que dans Tomb Raider 4 elle est
morte hein alors bon quand on fouille
les fichiers du jeu on peut trouver une
scène cinématique qui montre que Lara a
été sauvée par une chamane égyptienne
qui lui donne un artefact magique pour
la ressusciter sauf que cette scène
benelle a été supprimée donc du coup ben
on se contentera de jouer une Lara Croft
magique qui est revenue à la vie sans
explication bref la suite de la
cinématique d'intro nous montre donc une
dispute entre Lara et Werner le ton qui
monte quand soudainement un coup de
frein qui crie un coup de feu qui
retentit le caméraman devient fou gros
plan gros plan gros plan plan sous la
table et paf Werner est mort Lara a du
sang sur les mains terrible Lara
serait-elle donc une meurtrière alors
oui j'aurais peut-être pu y croire si la
version française c'était pas payé le
luxe de flinguer le scénard directement
en VO quand la dispute éclate Werner
crie get out sors
[Musique]
d'ici et effectivement VO on peut croire
à une dispute qui aurait mal tourné mais
en France il dit à
terre évidment ça marche plus là du coup
on comprend instantanément qu'il y avait
une troisème personne dans la pièce Le
scénare est déjà mort on a même pas
commencé à jouer encore vous voyez bien
que changer juste un mot ça peut rendre
une farandole incompréhensible quoi
exactement bref donc le jeu s'ouvre
lorsque la police arrive pour vous
interroger lâchez les chiens
d'interrogatoire après un niveau de tuto
et un passage où tu fuis la police le
jeu commence vraiment lorsque la race se
retrouve L
dans Paris la ville lumière la tour
montmre l'arc de triomp cloch prostu
habit
mal pas une étrangère vaendre la vie va
PL pour une qu'on une représentation
réaliste de la ville l'arrivé Paris ser
de minionde ouvert dans cette première
partie du jeu on sent l'inspiration de
mais c'est quand même plus que la ville
est
intégralement vide il y a personne à
part une voilà c'est la Seu
habitante de la ville et pour le reste
cet endroit sert à accéder à différents
lieux le magasin d'Arbor history le
monde piété auquel tu pourras vendre des
objets le petit parc le bar toute cette
phase de jeu consistera donc à parler à
des PN pour trouver un certain Gérard
Bouchard on parle donc d'abord à Janice
la prostituée qui nous dit d'ailleurs
que le cours de la passe est en Haos
dans Paris oui l'insécurité sans cesse
il est pris avec d'ailleurs ça m'arrange
voilà vous faites ce que vous voulez de
cette information et qui nous enverra
parler à d'autres personnage du coin et
première grosse nouveauté de ce jeu on a
différents embranchements de dialogue
unique il y a longtemps que vous
faites
belle il est pas dans le coin mignon il
avait le bar en face le serpent rouge il
est pas dans le coin mignon il avait le
bar en face le serpent rouge c'est une
rejouabilité infinie qui s'offre à moi
d'ailleurs pour parler technique je
glisse juste un petit mot sur les
dialogues en vraag donc on a la synchro
la bielle qui est littéralement
inexistante carvier ça alors les
personnages qui se redressent comme dans
des
cartoons et les cadrages qui sont tous
ratés la caméra se place n'importe où il
y a pas un dialogue dans le jeu qui a
réussi en fait tu vois le problème c'est
qu'on dirait que la caméra ne sait
jamais où se placer ah ouais je vois et
du coup on dirait que les personnages
regardent jamais au endroit bah ouais et
du coup ça fait des raccords bizarres
dans les dialogues et puis un des
problèmes d'avoir ces embranchements de
dialogue qui n'en sont pas c'est que
Lara a l'air complètement bipolaire et
va se mettre à menacer les gens comme ça
autour d'une phrase sans prévenir avant
de redevenir sympa juste après Bernard
vous me décevez beaucoup soyez prudent
la nuit sera noire et un accident est si
vite arrivé mademoiselle CR vous m'az
pas beaucoup pour votre défense là ah
oui et d'ailleurs deux petites dédicaces
à de moments du jeu que j'aime beaucoup
ce PN dans le jeu où visiblement alors
je pense qu'ils avaient dû oublier
d'animer ce dialogue et du coup sont bon
on va justeer l'image en espérant ça
voit pas
trop tea ensuite qu'il est éternellement
[Musique]
é et aussi ce moment sur réaliste dans
la version anglaise du
jeu bien tu aurais eu beaucoup de noix
de coco
quoi c'est peut-être une expression
anglaise ah non non j'ai vérifié ça
existe pas bref on va donc au bar où on
rencontre le patron qui nous dit qu'il
veut bien nous dire où est mais avant ça
il veut qu'on aille chercher quelque
chose pour lui nous sommes donc partis
pour le premier vrai donjon du jeu une
boîte de nuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vide ok je m'attendais pas à ça mais en
même temps ça me permet d'aborder un des
soucis de ce Tomb
Raider c'est qu'il n'y a pas de tombe ce
qui est un problème dans un Tomb Raider
alors tout ça rentre dans les études de
marketing qui ont été faites avant la
sortie du jeu où les marqueteux ont
décidé que les gens ne voulaient plus
voir de Tomb donc du coup bah la quasi
totalité du jeu se passera dans des
décors industriels ou modernes la boîte
de nuit des égoutts le Louvre des
égoutûts un chantier des égoutûs en fait
c'est pas que le level design est
mauvais mais Tomb Raider c'est censé
être de la découp couverte de lieux
abandonnés et majestueux d'anciennes
civilisation disparu elle est
archéologue je rappelle et là ben si le
personnage ne s'appelait pas Lara Croft
ben il y aurait rien qui ferait penser à
un Jeet Tom Raider bon alors donc on
récupère le quelque chose là dans la
boîte de nuit en activant divers
mécanismes avant de s'enfuir pour
retourner dans les rues de Paris je ne
suis pas assez forte ah merde ah je peux
pas ouvrir la porte je ne suis pas assez
forte ok donc là on est tous d'accord
que dans un jeu normal je devrais
normalement trouver une clé pour passer
cette porte dans un RPG plus abouti je
devrais avoir des stades de crochetage
ou de force pour la péter mais là
attention Tomb Raider a un système
unique qui n'a jamais été fait avant lui
ni refait après lui d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'il est unique en
fait qui a écrit ça à plusieurs moments
du jeu vous allez arriver sur des
endroits que vous ne pourrez pas
franchir parce que Lara vous dira je ne
suis pas assez forte je ne saute pas
assez loin et cetera ce qu'il faudra
faire dans ces cas-là est donc d'aller
utiliser un objet à proximité pousser un
bloc ou faire un sa plus petit ou Dieu
sait quoi pour en quelque sorte
entraîner son perso et avoir la force
nécessaire pour franchir l'obstacle
précédent et si cette tentative
d'introduire une notion de progression
dans ton Raider est déjà nul en théorie
en pratique c'est encore pire parce que
le jeu fait ça sans aucune logique plus
tard là il y a un moment où tu ne peux
pas ouvrir une porte en bois et donc
pour ouvrir cette porte en bois je dois
aller péter exactement la même porte en
bois de mett plus loin je me sens plus
forte mais le meilleur moment c'est dans
le niveau du Louvre il y a ce passage
hallucinant où vous ouvrez une porte de
placard et là Lara vous dit je suis plus
rapide qu c'est juste débile on avait
même commencé à écrire une blague pour
illustrer ça de manière rigolote mais
c'est même pas la peine en fait le jeu
c'est déjà une blague à lui tout
seul tout le jeu pue la peinture fraîche
rien n'est fini genre plus tard donc
vous rencontrez boucha et en sortant de
sa plan qu' a un autre de ces moments
trop bizarres où sans aucune une
explication Lara ve voler la montre en
or d'un pvga belle montre de quoi la
montre la vôtre je parle trop vite pour
vous mais c'est pas possible mais faites
la sortir faites quelque chose Lara tu
es littéralement millionnaire pourquoi
tu veux encore plus
d'argent non c'est logique en fait donc
ben vous prenez la montre en or de ce
pauvre mec et là au moment où on a écrit
ce texte et bien je l'ai toujours dans
mon inventaire est toujours là sert à
rien j'ai juste volé la montre en or
d'un pauvre gar dans la rue oui
l'insécurité augmente sans cesse alors
certes il existe un PN auquel tu peux
vendre des objets pour gagner de
l'argent sauf que à ce momentl du jeu ce
P il est déjà mort en fait clairement
ils avaient l'intention de faire quelque
chose avec l'argent dans ce jeu mais ils
ont pas eu le temps comme tout le reste
en fait bref donc après tout ce premier
passage le jeu nous oriente donc vers le
Louvre et on s'y rend avec tout le
respect habituel de Lara Croft pour les
uvres d'art et on va avoir droit à une
scène
d'infiltration e vous plus un geste et
c'est une fun tournage pour
l'infiltration là encore on est dans ce
truc du on n pas eu le temps de finir et
où de commencer je sais pas trop genre
par exemple le jeu nous permet de se
coller au mur pour voir les angles et
d'approcher discrètement pour assommer
les ennemis sauf que très vite bah tu te
rends compes que tout ça ne sert à rien
il n'y a aucune conséquence à tuer les
gens tu peux accéder aux mêmes endroits
ramasser les mêmes items tu peux
littéralement danser sous les caméras de
sécurité ça change rien alors il y a
bien une scène où déclencher l'alarme
ferme les grilles ce qui appelle un
gardien mais dès que tu le tues les
grilles se
rouvrent j'ai plus aucune nouvelle c'est
probablement que tout se passe bien du
coup on se retrouve dans ce cas
surréaliste où tu massacres des dizaines
de gardes dans le Louvre pour prouver
que tu n'as pas commis un meurtre vous
avez fait quoi bref après ce passage
d'infiltration on arrive au premier vrai
donjon et en réalité la seule et unique
tombe présente dans tout le jeu qui se
situe sous le Louvre à Paris et c'est là
où j'aurais bien aimé être une petite
souris pour voir les réunion des
développeurs pour le niveau 6 je pense
qu'il faut amer tout de suite là Phe de
test je pense que c'est important pour
mais pourquoi je sais pas ok là alors on
est à Paris là qu'est-ce qu'il y a sous
Paris qui pourrait nous servir de Djon
et catacomes un endroit genre sa où on
affrontrait des squelettes et catacombes
un endroit qui qui servirait de
labyrinthe quoi les catacombes Châtelet
et ok accrochez-vous à votre originalité
he parce que la seule et unique tombe
présente dans tout ce Tomb Raider est
un temple sur les quatre
éléments bravo bravo je propose que
toute l'équipe technique rentre dans le
champ pour applaudir donc je résume dans
ce jeu on a donc un donjon sur les
quatre éléments et trois niveaux dans
les éigou bravo c'est
incroyable ce niveau nous propose donc
qu air chacune basée sur le feu l'eau le
vent et les tremblements de terre mais
chacune avec le même problème c'est que
les sauts sont dégueulasses et je pense
que c'est le bon moment pour évoquer la
maniabilité qui m'a donné des envies de
meurtre donc pour bien vous expliquer
dans les précédents tomb Raiders les
jeux fonctionnaient tous avec un système
de grille tous les niveaux que ce soit
plateforme ou vide était divisé en cases
deux cases vides un saut normal trois
cases un saut plus agripage au rebord
quatre cases c'était un Solon bref donc
c'est comme ça qu'on changit la
puissance ce nouveau Tomb Raider n'a
plus du tout tout ça vous ne pouvez pas
gérer la puissance de vos sauts vous
sauter une distance fixe donc on se
retrouve régulièrement dans cette
situation stupide où vous passez votre
temps à mourir parce que vous faites un
saut trop long pour la taille du trou
devant vous allez oui oui oui oui non
non je vais tellement passer derrière je
vais tellement passer derrière je vais
je le savais c'était sûr mais le joueur
avisé se s'adapter pas de problème il
suffit juste que la race bouffe
absolument tous les murs du donjon dans
la face pour arrêter son
élan C tombe était vraiment
magnifique le plus gros dél de ce c'est
aussi le plus difficile à vous montrer
en en fait il y a un tlé sur absolument
tous les sauts c'est pour ça que vous
voyez régulièrement tomber des
plateformes sans
sauter est bien l' Sonor pour ce passage
je tombe et c'est pas un petit délai on
parle de quasiment une demi secondes de
l dans les saut ce jeu en fait va même à
l'encontre de 20 ans de jeux de
plateforme avant lui on t'a toujours
appris normalement dans les jeux à
gratter le dernier pixel de la
plateforme pour sauter loin sauf que
dans ce Tomb Raider il faut au contraire
sauter à mort plutôt pour prendre en
compte ce délai si tu joues un peu dans
le passé ça marche du coup après oui
c'est sûr qu'au bout de quelques heures
de jeu on s'habitue à tout anticiper de
de secondes mais mais zut quoi et puis
en plus ça a des conséquences pas cool
dans la vie
a du coup entre cette demise-seonde de
délai et le fait que vous ne pouvez pas
gérer la puissance de vos saut et que
donc une fois sur trois vous glissez
hors de la plateforme à l'atterrissage
sans exagération pour un jeu PS2 c'est
une horreur si vous voulez avancer il
faut sauvegarder quasiment à chaque
c'est un délire j'ai l'impression de
jouer sur stadia W W W va pas trop loin
quand même non mais ça va à un moment
les saut rendre le jeu complètement
injouable mais par contre ça ils ont pas
oublié de des tétons en 12 k à
l'ara avec phys 100 % réaliste ça ça
marche pourquoi je parlais déjà enfin
bref donc le niveau se termine par un
boss et j'ai même pas envie de vous
faire croire que ça sera peut-être bien
ici il faut ramasser un objet qui
n'arrête pas de se téléporter dès que
vous l'approchez la solution c'est qu'il
faut primo rester accroupi parce que le
saviez-vous les fantômes ne peuvent pas
vous toucher si vous êtes accroupis et
que secondo il faut vider votre chargeur
de fusil à pompe dessus parce que le
saviez-vous les fantômes sont sensibles
au balles de fusil à pompe hein voilà
regardez là on voit clairement qu'il
souffre hein bref vider son chargeur sur
le boss permettra pour Dieu c'est quelle
raison de stun le fantôme pendant
quelques secondes ce qui je ne sais pas
pourquoi empêchera l'objet que vous
étiez venu chercher de se téléporter
[Musique]
la terre est
[Applaudissements]
sauvée il y a un truc vraiment bizarre
avec les boss dans ce jeu je vous jure
ils sont ridicules alors il y a ce boss
là dont je viens de vous parler mais
plus tard dans le jeu il y a toute une
série de niveaux où le jeu te fait
monter la pression d'une espèce de
monstre trop horrible qui vous a pris en
chasse qui tue les gens ou là là ça fait
peur et quand vous l'affrontez
finalement ah mon Dieu mais où est-il on
entend que c'est bruit de pas il
pourrait surgir de n'importe ah ben non
il est
[Musique]
là et là vous vous demandez peut-être
mais qui était donc ce mystérieux beau
séduisant et ténébreux personnage que
j'étais en train de jouer et bien il
s'agit de Curtis le nouveau personnage
de la saga des tomb Raiders en sortant
du temple des éléments vous revenez vers
le Louvre mais soudainement vous tombez
sur un mystérieux personnage qu'on a
déjà croisé plutôt dans le jeu et qui
vous désarme lentement
[Musique]
Sonic va vous causer Sonic va vous
parler les enfants votre corps vous
appartient personne n'a le droit d'y
toucher si vous vous y opposez que faire
dans ces cas-là hein vous dites NON
Curtis vous vole donc l'artefact et
s'enfuit dans le musée et apparemment il
possède la
force ah et puis vas-y je m'en fous
allez vas-y roule vous le poursuivez à
travers le Louvre quant au détour d'un
couloir vous le voyez qui vous attend
sur le bord d'une rambarde pour vous
faire un signe de la main trop classe en
vous nargant avant de s'échapper
ok alors ma théorie c'est que je pense
qu'à ce moment-là ils ont collé deux
cinématiques qui étaient normalement
espacé par un niveau la preuve éant que
soudainement pouf Lara a des lunettes de
soleil qu'elle avait pas de secondes
avant il faut savoir que angel of
darkness a vu énormément de niveau être
supprimé de son développement au
détriment de la logique de l'histoire on
peut voir ça à plein de moment où on a
des choses étranges qui se passent genre
Lara passe une porte avec un pantalon et
paf de l'autre côté elle est en short et
Curtis c'est certainement celui qui a le
plus morflé dans ce jeu et c'est triste
mourir Curtis c'était censé être le
début de quelque chose ça devait être un
nouveau personnage avec ses propres
pouvoirs il est même sur le livret il
devait avoir ses propres jeux sauf que
par manque de temps et ben ces pouvoirs
que le joueur devait utiliser de manière
libre ben sont juste devenus des scènes
cinématiques et niveau gameplay B il
n'est plus rester qu'une espèce de clone
de Lara qui a juste droit à des niveaux
un peu plus orientés baston enfin bon au
moins il lui reste s carisme écart qu'
utilisé les CIN peintures d'Obscura pour
animer un vieux démon appelé le dormeur
faire revivre les
néphilimes dans ce but il rassemble des
éléments des corps de ses victimes
transformés par
l'alchimie alors honnêtement je pourrais
aller plus loin et vous parler de chaque
niveau du jeu mais à quoi bon et le jeu
se termine sur deux boss incroyables le
premier qui se tue avec la légendaire
technique tu me touches pas parce que je
suis accroupi et le deuxième qui me fait
penser à un truc que tu verrais dans un
train fantôme quelqu'un peut me dire
comment on s'arrête je je t'attrape si
je vais te mettre espèce de GR et c'est
fini la retourne dans
l'ombre après ce jeu le directeur du
studio a arrêté de bosser dans le jeu
vidéo la licence a été retirée à
corordesign et la boîte a fait
faillite bilan mitigé donc on va pas se
mentir la licence atterrira chez les
Américains de Crystal Dynamics qui
publieront trois jeux Tomb Raider Legend
Tomb Raider Anniversary et Tomb Raider
Underworld trois jeux plutôt bons certes
mais qui finalement commercialement
auront assez peu de succès la licence
Tomb Raider s'arrêtera donc une deuxième
fois avant de revenir finalement en 2013
en ayant fait le grand tour puisque
entre-etemps Uncharted avait commencé en
s'inspirant de Tomb Raider et quand les
derniers tomb Raiders reviendront ils se
sonont eux-mêmes inspirés de
Uncharted je crois qu'on arrive
[Musique]
bon on attend quoi écoutez ce plan a été
extrêmement galère à faire alors ditien
profiter du
[Musique]
spectacle
mon tu étais mon
ami je vais devoir faire sans toi à
présent
[Musique]
caramen j'ai une devinette pour vous je
suis entre 189 et 191 mais je ne suis
pas 190
qui
suisje un
pouletêes complètement con en fait P
nécoutez pas cette femme ACC une deè
chance pour laisser
passeriss je
pasz comme ça n pas gardien je
blo DEP des
siè pas résoudreig
vous aussi vous êtes à la poursuite du
dollar vert et pari ça fait des lunes
que je subis cette malédiction à chaque
fois que j'essaie d'entourner une
chanson il se passe quelque chose
d'étrange
écoutez tu parles avec une Anissa mais
moi je
m'appelle oh Tian tisan vous voyez à
chaque fois c'est pareil ah
je crois que j'ai compris il s'agit de
mécanisme pour ouvrir la
porte laissez-moi essayer
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Benoît de la brigade
super sympa et moi c'est Sophie de la
brigade des supers amis vous avez faim
on fait des soiré gaufes tous les soirs
et ce sont des gaufes super sympas non
c'est gentil on est un peu pressé là
nous sommes à la recherche du mystérieux
dollar vert est-ce que vous savez où il
est le dollar vert bien sûr il est juste
là à côté de la machine à
café attendez c'est tout c'est ça le
doar ver vous voulez dire qu'on peut le
prendre comme ça bah oui évidemment tout
le monde peut prendre le dollar
[Musique]
vert
oh qui c'est qui a récupéré le dollar
on ça
va oh non votre ami a m'u les règles
d'utilisation c'est dramatique un petit
maquato attendez quoi notre ami vient de
crever un double du coup mais vous êtes
des vous êtes odieux en fait vous dites
que tout le monde est libre de s'en
emparer mais c'est ça la liberté devoir
obéir à des règles stupide sans aucun
sens et qui change tout le temps et puis
pourquoi en fait pour satisfaire vos
délires du moment et puis de toute façon
depuis quand c'est à vous de décider
tout ça pour qui vous vous
prenez pardon vous disiez quelque chose
ok bah si c'est comme ça moi je ben
voilà ça roule
[Musique]
au fait monsieur comment s'est passé
votre dernière
aventure pas de trésor ce quoci Winston
mais au moins je me suis fait un nouveau
compagnon
[Musique]
tu as pas quelque chose à boire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]